entre les immeubles récents et les
divers commerces difficiles de retrouver
dans la rue Victor mccoli le charme de
Saint-Denis d'antan pourtant si l'on s'y
attarde un peu il reste ça et là
quelques constructions authentiques mais
il reste-t-il aussi quelques souvenirs
de Victor mccollif
qui était Victor mcoli fin bonne
question
du McDonald's
sa fille est à l'origine des broderies
de Cilaos
si Victor mccoli fait entrer dans
l'histoire locale c'est à cause de son
dévouement Victor n'est à Zanzibar le 7
mars 1870 d'un papa médecin
arrivé tout jeune à la Réunion il
décroche son baccalauréat dans l'unique
lycée de Lille à l'époque un diplôme qui
lui ouvre les portes de l'école de santé
des armées de Lyon sur les traces de son
père Victor devient donc chirurgien
notre docteur part comme médecin
militaire en 1895 à Madagascar ou la
guerre férale
la grande île devient possession
française et macauliffrevient au pays
pour soigner les civils son dévouement
est très apprécié par les malades
le bon docteur est de nouveau mobilisé
par la Grande Guerre
à la fin du conflit il revient dans son
île là il enseigne à la maternité et à
l'hôpital colonial avant de les diriger
un directeur très apprécié pour son
humanisme et sa charité
c'est aussi un père très aimé de ses
enfants et de leur maman
malgré une santé fragilisée à bord de sa
légendaire voiture monocylindre Victor
soignera ainsi les Dionysiens pendant
près de 30 ans
le 21 juillet 1930 trois ans après sa
mort son bus était érigé dans la cour de
l'hôpital militaire une reconnaissance
qui s'ajoute aux médailles qui l'ont
décorées de son vivant la médaille
commémorative de Madagascar et la croix
de la Légion d'honneur